bonjour bienvenue sur le sentier
botanique de la providence
qui si on se trouve sur le sentier
pédagogique qui se trouve aux portes de
la ville de saint denis et au pied du
massif du grand brûlé ce sentier
découverte a été conçu par le
conservatoire botanique des mascareignes
et a été pilotée par le pôle éco
tourisme de louannec
on a fuit conducteur c'est un couple de
caméléon ici vous pouvez voir donc la
petite femelle cam qui se trouve donc
sur les étiquettes botanique de façon
très discrète
sur ce sentier on trouve 12 stations
équipées de 12 pitre interactif et
ludique on peut découvrir un certain
nombre d'espèces qui font partie de
notre environnement proche de notre
quotidien des espèces dites endémique
indigènes ou exotiques
sur cette station qui se trouve à
l'entrée du sentier on trouve les
espèces exotiques le panier colonnes qui
se trouve juste là à proximité et donc
qui est signifiée par la couleur bleue
parce que c'est justement une espèce
exotique pour les autres trièdre on
trouvera la couleur verte pour les
espèces indigènes et endémiques et la
couleur orange pour les espèces
exotiques voir envahissante
retrouvez toutes les informations
pratiques dans le mini guide du sentier
de la providence à télécharger
gratuitement sur le site internet de
l'ot nf